alors l'exercice on le sait inédit pour
le président de la République c'est sa
première conférence de presse et pas
dans n'importe quel contexte on vous le
rappelle si besoin pose gilet jaune pose
grand débat avec un plan de
communication perturbé par l'incendie de
Notre-Dame alors comment va-t-il se
plier à l'exercice on le sait dans ce
genre de rendez-vous la forme ça compte
aussi elle sera observée de près et je
vous demande tout de suite Marion
qu'attendez-vous la conférence de presse
est-ce que c'est du pain béni pour
Emmanuel Macron qui comme on l'a dit est
plutôt bon dans les questions réponses
dans le la spontanéité ou quand même ils
jouent j'ai envie de vous dire les deux
parce qu'en effet c'est un exercice les
questions réponses il est habile dans
cet exercice il a eu un certain
entraînement depuis quatre mois avec le
grand débat et en même temps les
journalistes il a du mal avec les
journalistes il sait pas exactement
comment les prendre il y a une sorte de
mépris qui s'est installée depuis le
début du quinquennat il n'a jamais fait
de conférence de presse donc c'est pas
un exercice avec les journalistes qui
lui est familier et puis les
journalistes ont un certain nombre de
questions lui poser vous avez parlé du
grand débat gilet jaune Notre-Dame mais
il y a aussi l'affaire Benalla on l'a
peut entendu dessus directement quelques
sujets qui va devoir aborder et qui
peuvent être un peu éruptifs donc on va
voir comment ça se passe et puis c'est
pas tout à fait comme dans le grand
débat ou les mers ou les élus
rencontraient poser une question mais
pas vraiment de droit de suite là on
peut imaginer qui est quelquefois des
journalistes qui sont un peu insistants
alors tout dépend de la forme de la
conférence de presse on en parlait juste
avant d'entrer en plateau en principe
une conférence de presse vous avez un
journaliste qui pose une question et
puis les autres journalistes en braille
pour donner un droit de suite à cette
question et faire vivre la question s'il
n'y a pas eu de réponse ensuite le
président peut choisir de prendre une
série de questions ce qui est plus
facile pour lui d'éviter des questions
et des relances un peu sensibles
dernière parole mais juste l'état
d'esprit de vos confrères vous
connaissez justement ce qui suivent
enfin qui sont à l'Elysée là qui devait
y être déjà 320 journalistes et ils ont
l'intention de oui c'est vraiment
l'occasion qu'il aurait doté de oui
c'est ça c'est la première occasion donc
il faut pas la rater et on attend tous
des réponses donc les questions vont
être posées encore une fois on va voir
comment s'en sort Emmanuel Macron alors
avec les poulain par exemple vous en
parliez avant avec Marion alors
qu'est-ce que vous disiez
déjà le temps de la parole puisqu'il
aime bien parler et prendre son temps
donc quand on va s'arrêter cette
conférence de presse combien de temps
elle va durer
dans les cueille de faire un truc
interminable alors je pense que là il va
peut-être éviter parce qu'il y a des
questions qui fâchent évidemment parce
que c'est des journalistes et c'est pas
un public comme ça a été le public
caster du grand débat les mers enfin où
il y avait peu de questions finalement
sortaient du chapeau là il va avoir
affaire j'espère à de mordant
journaliste qui ont envie d'avoir des
réponses ça peut aussi tourner
à la langue de bois plus plus et l'idée
en fait c'est de faire de la pédagogie
comme il l'appelle à chaque fois
d'expliquer pourquoi il faut aller plus
vite plus loin dans son programme et
finalement on a l'impression que le
grand n'a jamais eu lieu et qu'on va
avoir droit à une série de mesures qui
vont être
un succès du programme en marche avec
quelques petits trucs des magots comme
la suppression de l'ENA enfin les choses
qui ont déjà fuité la semaine dernière
mais le grand débat c'était le moment où
on devait écouter les Français et ça
devient le moment où on écoute le
Président c'est quand même assez cocasse
Gabriel Cluzel quels sont vos critères
pour juger de cette prestation sur la
forme on est toujours sur la forme pas
je vous parle pas du fond dont on va
parler on va voir effectivement là
Emmanuel Macron va vraiment montrer de
quoi il est capable parce que jusqu'à
présent le grand débat qui a été un peu
conçu comme un séminaire d'entreprise
finalement avec un côté boîte à idées et
puis comme un professeur dans une école
un quotasymétrique aussi c'est quand
même un peu un village potenkin les gens
étaient dans leur petit souliers c'est
normal quand on est un jeune quand on
est quelqu'un d'ordinaire de s'adresser
au président de la République la les
journalistes c'est autre chose donc on
va vraiment voir de quoi il est capable
moi je
mon souci c'est que Emmanuel Macron est
précisément trop bon dans la forme la
forme de bien sur le fond
esthétorique enfin énorme et on en
oublie le fond je crois que les Français
attendent le fond on sait bien qu'il est
qu'il est bon sur la forme mais s'il y a
trop de l'englobe de bois si on a
l'impression qu'il a lu le guide des 40
astuces pour éviter les pièges à l'oral
de l'ENA et bien il ne réussira pas son
exercice ce qui fait peur c'est que un
certain nombre de mesures ont été
éventés il y a ça a été spoilé comme on
dit alors on peut dire que c'est un
point pour lui positif parce que ça a
été un ballon d'essai mais en même temps
l'effet du côté effectivement
je vous donne la parole je vous oublie
pas Nicolas pas vrai juste j'aurais
parce que vous faisiez allusion à ce
grand débat et parfois l'exercice un peu
convenu on vous a préparé Charlotte
Darche qui prépare cette émission avec
moi vous a préparé un petit florilège
des quelques points forts de ce grand
débat on le regarde des gens qui crèvent
et alors qui travaillent il y en a marre
[Applaudissements]
elle est pas là pour faire des choses
puisque c'est l'argent qui nous a amené
à négliger l'écologie
vous pensez qu'on pourra acheter une
nouvelle planète avec de l'argent
je peux pas de là où je suis seul dire
c'est zéro ou sans du jour au lendemain
on doit faire c'est une transition moi
je pense que les intellectuels ont cette
responsabilité parce qu'ils ont une
autorité dans la société qui est
académique c'est ils savent plus de
choses si je devais parler simplement
ils ont le plus de livres est-ce que
parfois comme étant de
la verticalité c'était simplement de
reconnaître que tout se valait pas et
toutes les paroles ne se valent pas à
tout moment surtout sujet
on vient de voir très moment très
différent Nicolas baveray quel serait le
temps juste selon vous je crois que donc
il y a eu trois moments il y a cette
crise des gilets jaunes qui est
d'ailleurs toujours ouverte et en termes
d'ordre public et en termes de mesure ou
de pacte économiques et sociales pour en
sortir ensuite il y a eu le grand débat
qui a quand même été largement biaisé
parce que ça a été beaucoup plus une
mise en scène du président de la
République et puis maintenant il y a le
temps de l'action qui est quand même le
temps de la politique puisque donc la
première question c'est alors que il
faut être clair tout le système de
décision publique est quand même arrêté
depuis six mois à l'exception de la loi
d'exception sur Notre-Dame dont on
parlera peut-être mais qui me paraît
poser plus de problèmes qu'elle n'en
règle mais donc tout est à l'arrêt donc
la première question c'est est-ce qu'on
arrive à remettre de l'action le
quinquennat en marche sans mauvais jeu
de mots et la deuxième question elle
concerne le président lui-même le lien
avec les Français avaient été
considérablement altéré d'une certaine
manière le lien avec les courses
intermédiaires n'est que les causes
intermédiaires que ce soit des
journalistes ou les élus ou les
syndicalistes les représentants des ce
qu'on appelle les forces vives avec des
courroies de transmission vers l'opinion
donc le grand débat incontestablement
permis un début de rattrapage ou de
reconstitution maintenant ce qui est clé
dans cette dans cette conférence de
presse c'est est-ce qu'il arrive à
rétablir le lien avec les Français et je
pense qu'il ne peut le faire que s'il
tient compte d'un certain nombre
d'erreurs qu'il a commises et qu'il
remet vraiment en question son système
de pouvoir autrement dit les erreurs sur
la forme puisqu'on est encore sur la
forme c'est quoi c'est les petites
phrases c'est quoi c'est le vous savez
c'est toujours le
Carniel de Retz pour un homme public il
convient moins encore de dire des
bêtises que d'en faire et je crois que
les il y a les petites phrases mais je
pense qu'il y a plus grave il y a ce
système de pouvoir qui était
complètement autoritaire centralisée
technocratique et qui était donc qui
s'est installé un peu un peu hors sol et
surtout finalement ce qui est très
paradoxal un mépris absolu pour la
politique le général de Gaulle en 1958
on peut pas accuser le général de Gaulle
d'avoir eu trop d'estime pour les élus
les parties et les hommes de parties
mais générale de Gaulle il s'est quand
même donné la peine d'organiser un parti
Go List qui avec ses qualités et ses
défauts structurer la vie politique de
la France pendant 25 ans là aujourd'hui
le parti du président est énorme il est
énorme en termes de vie et de soi-disant
justement est-ce qu'on peut pas dire
qu'on est plus en 68 et que les 30 ans
après l'organisation générale d'un parti
de la société n'est décisif pourquoi
parce que c'est toute l'ambiguïté
d'Emmanuel Macron il s'est d'une
certaine manière ce qui va devoir
trancher parce que il s'est installé
comme principal leader pour contrer le
populisme mais il en a une vraie
dimension parce que si vous voulez qui
est-ce qui refuse les corps
intermédiaires qui ce qui refusent les
parties ce qui refuse la vie
parlementaire pour installer un dialogue
direct entre un homme fort et le peuple
est entre un homme fort et ses
homologues qui est-ce que qui refuse de
tenir compte de l'état de droit des
institutions de précisément les
populations donc ceux qui doit trancher
aujourd'hui fondamentalement c'est ça et
de quel côté est-ce qu'il est pour de
bon et ça ça veut dire que le en même
temps c'est terminé c'est la vieille
formule de Mendès France gouverner ses
choisir présider c'est choisir aussi et
derrière le style est-ce que enfin il
accepte de remettre de la politique dans
son système de fonctionnement d'accepter
d'avoir des contradicteurs à l'intérieur
et pas seulement à l'extérieur c'est à
mon avis ça les deux éléments clés
est-ce qu'il a il accepte ou il en
manque de contradicteurs on le dit
souvent il est seul les mets de côté en
tout cas dans son propre parti et c'est
pour ça que si on a atteint les limites
dure en même temps on atteint aussi les
limites du Nouveau Monde c'est à dire
que depuis trois ans on nous vanter un
nouveau monde où justement il y avait
des nouvelles pousses des élus sans
expérience politique alors c'est vrai
que les Français réclamaient des
nouvelles têtes mais aujourd'hui
justement Emmanuel Macron manque de gens
d'expérience autour de lui et on l'a vu
depuis quatre ou cinq mois et même avant
avec l'affaire Benalla il manque de
contradicteurs il manque de gens qui lui
mettent des limites aussi qui lui disent
là on va dans le mur et on le voit en
termes de communication c'est à dire que
ceux qui étaient à l'Élysée sont partis
au gouvernement sont devenus ministres
et donc aujourd'hui il manque aussi de
conseiller en communication à l'Élysée
donc voilà on voit qu'il y a une sorte
de château de sable qui s'effrite un peu
il peut très bien reprendre la main il
est assez habile il est intelligent mais
ce soir on aura on va en savoir plus
justement là dessus je reviens sur une
expression à l'équipe poulain qui est
qu'il a utilisé c'était je sais plus
exactement quand j'ai été scarifiée par
ce par ce qui s'est passé
mais ça fait partie de ces petites
phrases qui rendent les gens fous de
colère en fait parce qu'en face de de
cette petite phrase il y a les
manifestants qui ont perdu un œil qui
ont perdu une main un pied qui eux ont
était scarifié et avis
d'empathie de d'être proche des gens et
dès qu'il dit quelque chose
ensuite le lui reprocher mais le choix
des mots compte il est très fort en
symbole Emmanuel Macron rappelez-vous sa
prise de pouvoir sous la pyramide enfin
il a fait plein de clin d'œil et l'hymne
à la joie etc donc il sait très bien
jouer avec les symboles quand
c'est pas anodin et c'est extrêmement
maladroit mais mais toute sa
communication est plus que maladroite et
la catastrophique l'affaire Benalla en
24 heures c'était plié si la
communication avait été correcte
commencée par se défendre par un
mensonge demandait à ce power Bruno
Roger petit de mentir il était
porte-parole mais il savait pas qu'on
lui donnait des éléments d'engage qui
était complètement faux c'est
catastrophique et on déroule le fil du
mensonge comme le livre de Villiers et
on découvre quoi que derrière le
progressisme c'est du vide c'est à dire
que vous avez en plus quand monsieur
Émilien a fait le tour des plateaux avec
Monsieur Amiel pour vendre son livre en
disant voilà je suis le cerveau du
progressisme et qu'on découvre en fait
que c'est la novlangle de startups qui
ne veut rien dire maximiser les
opportunités etc tous ensemble c'est une
catastrophe et pour Emmanuel Macron
c'était censé être son cerveau donc la
fuite des cerveaux de l'Elysée déjà
montre que les cerveaux sont quand même
pas très très construits politiquement
et on voit bien enfin voilà Nathalie
Loiseau qui a du mal à assumer son passé
et qui confond maoïsme
pour dire que ça manque de profondeur ça
manque de réflexion et ça manque de
politique comme vous le disiez je donne
la parole un petit peu à nos internautes
la conférences de presse est-elle
uniquement vous demandez-t-on un peu
provocatrice un show présidentiel et
bien vous êtes 72% à estimé que oui Rick
c'est ainsi que ce prénom notre
internaute ce sera un show si les
journalistes sont mauvais ce qui est pas
faux c'est aussi on dit beaucoup c'est
le président qui c'est un gros enjeu
pour le président mais ça dépend aussi
de la façon dont les journalistes ça
dépend aussi s'ils sont libres de poser
les questions c'est-à-dire que si c'est
pas choisi et si on ne prend pas
quelques têtes en se disant la question
sera gentil donc il faut qu'il y ait
aussi une vraie liberté des journalistes
de faire leur travail c'est un test
aussi pour les journalistes parce que il
faut quand même bien sûr
les gilets jaunes ça a été aussi
l'occasion de montrer qu'il y a une
profession j'en fais partie donc je je
dois aussi faire preuve d'humidité mais
qui est détestait c'est celle des
journalistes parce que les gens le
sentiment que ils ne sont pas ils ne
sont pas là pour tourner le faire dans
la plaie comme le disait Albert Londres
et qui n'ont pas joué leur rôle donc si
là effectivement comme on a eu les
députés godillot on a des journalistes
de godillot ça paraîtra excessivement
décevant évidemment il y a une façon de
verrouiller les conférences de presse
comme vous le disiez néanmoins ce sera
au journaliste qui sont présents ce soir
de faire en sorte de montrer que on va
gratter là où ça fait mal parce que
sinon ce sera un véritable échec moi je
pense simplement je reviens aux univers
dont vous parliez tout à l'heure cette
façon c'est
en même temps qui a été une façon de
faire campagne et c'est terrible parce
qu'on voit qu'elle a été extrêmement
efficace pour faire campagne c'est
finalement une technique commerci social
on crée des univers différents comme
dans les magasins et qui permet de
draguer si j'ose dire vulgairement un
peu de tous les côtés et puis on se rend
compte que finalement dans la vie
politique c'est délétère parce qu'on
arrive à cette archipel dont parlé
qui est maintenant on veut retrouver un
lien qu'on a détruit je crois que le
symbole le plus le plus frappant c'était
il n'y a pas une culture française mais
des cultures françaises ça satisfaisait
tout le monde parce que chacun pouvait
retrouver la sienne ou celle qui pensait
être la sienne
pendant la campagne et maintenant on se
rend compte que c'est terrible de se
retrouver avec aucun socle commun est-ce
que Nicolas est-ce qu'il doit y avoir on
l'a dit l'effet de surprise il est un
peu maintenant émoussé et ce qui doit y
avoir une ou des annonces spectaculaires
en fait je ne suis pas certain parce que
c'est vrai que à travers cette
conférence de presse c'est là encore une
très grande ambiguïté c'est à dire soit
on rejoue l'homme providentiel tout le
pays s'arrête on a tendance que Jupiter
tonne et que et de savoir si ça repart
ou pas en réalité il y a aucun pays
moderne qui peut fonctionner de cette de
cette manière là donc je crois que ce
qui a été dit et tout à fait juste c'est
à dire que les annonces soi-disant
spectaculaires c'est soit de la
communication de la démagogie pure par
exemple ce qui a été annoncé sur la
suppression de l'ENA voir de l'école de
la magistrature aussi c'est clair que
ces écoles peuvent avoir des défauts
mais c'est certainement pas en les
supprimant qu'on va ni faire marcher la
justice ni réformer l'État
soit des mesures strictement
catégorielles avec un peu pour les
retraités un peu avec pour le monde
rural etc et en fait ce dont on manque
absolument cruellement c'est un projet
politique qui permet de remettre les
citoyens ensemble et de rétablir aussi
l'unité l'unité du territoire de
finalement de que les de refaire la
France ou en tout cas que les que les
Français se ressentent un peu français
on a vu exactement le processus
c'est ce qui est arrivé mais on a eu les
deux effets sur Notre-Dame c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a eu un soir ou ça ça a marché
et malheureusement dès le lendemain on a
été rattrapé par des choses et c'est pas
ça c'était éparpillé entre les
polémiques sur le rôle de l'Église sur
le montant des dons sur la fiscalité
donc si vous voulez l'important pour lui
c'est d'arriver à être dans le climat
qui a été le climat à la fois de de
recueillement et
d'unités des Français le lundi 15 avril
au soir devant le spectacle de
Notre-Dame s'il arrive à faire ça je
pense que c'est plus important que
d'aller annoncer je sais pas trop quoi
avec en plus toujours un problème en
France c'est que les c'est franchement
ça a été le cas sur les annonces de la
fin de l'année 2018 c'est comme par
ailleurs ces annonces ne sont pas
préparées ne sont pas évalués on a un
gouvernement totalement technocratique
mais on n'a pas le bon côté de la
technocratie c'est à dire qu'on a ni
évaluation ni calculer
dans l'urgence
oui mais si c'est pour refaire ce genre
de choses on est payé pour savoir que ça
n'a aucun sens puisque on a quand même
engagé 11 milliards c'est-à-dire plus
d'un demi points de pipe pour rien alors
on parle justement de ce cap
effectivement le 10 décembre le
président de la République avait dit au
plus fort de la crise des gilets jaunes
nous ne reprendrons pas le cours normal
de nos vies autant dire